less than a kilometer off the western
coast of scotland
a small low-lying island languishes in
the calm blue-gray waters of a protected
bay
the mid-morning sun gives the heath and
grass of velvety smoothness
the calm only punctuated by the bleating
of sheep drifting across the narrow
stretch to the mainland
it is 1942
the height of the second world war
there is a flash and several seconds
later a boom crackles and pierces the
highland quiet
a faint brown cloud rises and drifts
with the prevailing wind obscuring for a
while the crisp island horizon
from the mainland shore scientists peer
at the dispersing stain intently through
binoculars praying silently that the
wind will not turn and blow the deadly
cloud towards them for this cloud now so
thinned to be almost invisible
is not smoke or a chemical gas but a
fine
bacterial dust
the bacteria are bacillus anthracis
and this grignard island is the site of
britain's first and only test of anthrax
in biological warfare
anthrax can be deadly to all mammals and
indeed all 80 sheep left grazing on the
island soon perished from the infection
in this sense the test was a success
proving that anthrax delivered by bomb
would be potent enough to lay waste to
entire german cities
but while the cloud of brown dust may
have been quick to disappear the
bacteria themselves proved more
tenacious
grignard island was thoroughly
contaminated with this deadly microbe
unable to support any mammalian life
either sheep or human
decades passed with no change to the
toxic exclusion zone with not even the
bleating of sheep to disturb the
abandoned silence
[Music]
the island stood alone for 50 years as
an extreme unlivable environment within
an otherwise green and pleasant modern
world
only after intense campaigning did the
government finally take steps to
decontaminate the island of its anthrax
infestation
but while the soil was made livable
again after half a century
the rocks that make up the island and
mainland nearby date back to a time when
almost the entire globe was a toxic
exclusion zone
one billion years ago there were entire
hemispheres where certain life forms
simply couldn't survive with exotic
microbes disturbing the status quo
just as we couldn't live on corrupted
grignard island
so too would we perish on the
billion-year-old earth
a time traveler would find themselves
disoriented by shorter days asphyxiated
by a cocktail of noxious gases in the
atmosphere bombarded by ultraviolet rays
and horrified by a hellscape of black
sludgy oceans and barren land
and while grignard's horrors lasted only
50 years
the earth was condemned
for much longer
for one billion years ago the earth
entered a new geological age
the neoproterozoic
but this is a boundary in name alone
chosen only to mark the passing of a
comfortably round number of millions of
years
for in reality the planet is still mired
in stasis a period of tedium that began
800 million years before and is destined
to last for another 200 million years
this bizarre chapter of earth's history
affectionately termed the boring billion
sees land ocean atmosphere and life all
stuck
in a rut
nothing changes nothing revolutionary
happens to break the planet out of its
toxic slump for a full thousand million
years
but at this turn of a new era
all
is not as it seems
[Music]
island once the toxic exception to the
habitable rule was at one time home to a
miraculous neoproterozoic
paradise
when all else on earth was putrid and
hostile the clouds break to let the sun
shine onto a green and pleasant refuge
cradled protected from the global merc
tantalizing winds of change blow in the
neoproterozoic air
could this be a sign that things are
about to change
is this the answer to the end
of the boring billion
and the beginning
of our world
[Music]
a billion years ago life lived almost
entirely under the ocean and that
diversity has continued to the present
day head over to our sponsors curiosity
stream to check out david attenborough
explaining and exploring the bizarre
fascinating world of the deep ocean
here creatures from the far distant past
still survive
seven miles below the surface in the
mariana trench an incredible ecosystem
thrives it's like an alien planet on the
surface of the earth and that's just one
of curiosity streams more than 3 000
documentaries to choose from it's like a
huge netflix for factual content
so head over to curiositystream.com
forward slash history of the earth to
sign up and using the promo code history
of the earth will save you 25 percent
bringing a full year down to 14.99
just over a dollar a month
thanks
[Music]
when french explorer etienne brule set
foot on the island of the menong in the
northern reaches of lake superior in
1622 he was not the first to do so
indeed it was the native american tribes
who had told him of the island and
taught him the ways of the lake which
had allowed him to paddle safely to it
in the cross-cutting winds and currents
the natives had long used the bays and
inlets as fertile fishing grounds but in
thrashing through the wilderness the
frenchman saw that activity on the
island long predated that of his guides
there were mounds and pits scrapes in
the bare surface of the rock
exposing seams and streaks of lurid blue
green and every now and then a glimpse
of metallic orange
later explorers gave the natives minong
a new name isle royale and more thorough
investigations of the curious earthworks
revealed their remarkable antiquity
these were mines and excavations dating
back some four and a half thousand years
to some of the very first indigenous
peoples who would colonize the area
after the last great ice age here the
prehistoric aborigines had uncovered
huge and miraculous deposits of pure
copper metal within the basaltic rocks
and it worked over hundreds of years to
extract it with a little more than fire
and simple stone tools
the copper had been forged into knives
for hunting and jewelry for trading
helping the nameless ancestral natives
to secure their dominance within the
wilds of america
isle royale and the shores of lake
superior are now known to contain the
most important native copper deposits in
the world
copper can be found in huge quantities
in its pure metallic form making it an
attractive prospect for miners from
prehistoric times to today
and all that copper came to be
concentrated around the great lake
thanks to an event one billion years ago
that nearly ripped the american
continent
in half
one billion years ago our planet has
already spent three and a half thousand
million years under the glow of our sun
the globe's spin has slowed and now some
18 hours passes between one sunrise and
the next
the moon which for so long has loomed a
large in the young planet's skies has
robbed the earth of angular momentum to
drift imperceptibly further from us with
each passing month and is now just 30
000 miles from its modern position
every full moon appears as a super moon
in the neoproterozoic
from a molten hellscape earth has
gradually cooled crust has formed and
differentiated water has been delivered
concentrated cycled atmospheric gases
accumulate and are two cycled by
chemistry and the seemingly novel
terrestrial innovation biology as the
maturing sun brightens and warms it
delivers more heat to our world
offsetting the loss of greenhouse gases
to the hungry biological and chemical
factories the climate warms and cools in
step with internal transformations and
feedbacks bringing icy deserts and
tropical storms in equal measure
air ocean and land are under a state of
constant flux and reconfiguration as
plate tectonics after a stumbling start
now reshapes the surface in earnest
by one billion years ago the majority of
the continental crossed on earth has
assembled into a single concentrated
mass but spanning both hemispheres as
far as the northern and southern
sub-arctic
this single supercontinent is rhodinia
rodinia is merely the latest in a
sequence of supercontinents formed when
buoyant and long-lasting continental
crust comes together and then tears
itself apart under the titanic and
unstoppable forces of plate tectonics
it follows the first columbia which
reigned from the end of the archaean
through to the earliest years of the
proterozoic and it will be followed by
panosha gondwana and pangaea
but not before the end of the boring
billion
large-scale trends suggesting that the
earth at this point has been stuck in a
kind of stasis for 800 million years
but while this may be broadly true
rodinia itself has not continued
unchanged for all this time
tectonic forces born in the churning
interior of the planet do not simply
grind to a halt despite the congested
clot of continents on the surface
the ancient terrains that make up the
supercontinent slide shuffle and exploit
lines of weakness to try and accommodate
the leviathan molten forces beneath
one of these shuffles saw the ancient
continental plate of laurentia which
contains the bulk of modern north
america collide with the rio plateau and
amazonia which now makes up the heart of
south america this slow motion collision
saw the first subduction of an ancient
ocean basin stretching and bending the
crust either side and building crumpled
volcanic mountain ranges very much like
the modern day andes in the hearts of
the growing mountains rocks are
superheated to change their composition
and are folded like so many soft pastry
layers
these are the same processes that occur
deep below the surface of the modern day
himalayas as the indian subcontinent
forces its way into eurasia it becomes
impossible to say where one continent
ends and gives way to the next
this fusing of vast continental masses
is known as the grenville orogeny and it
occurs along a battlefront that spans
the entirety of modern day north america
the rocks and structures created during
these tumultuous ages one billion years
ago now persist in a belt that runs from
labrador down to mexico in the heart of
the appalachians the adirondacks and the
laurentian mountains of canada
but there is another surprising remnant
of this billion-year-old redinion
reshuffle to be found in the eastern
part of america
at a time when the dominant tectonic
forces were clear in their intention to
fuse laurentia with its neighbors
other forces were contriving to tear the
wrencher itself
apart
as the ancient grenville ocean is
swallowed beneath the laurentian
continent the oceanic crust at its base
sinks deep into the mantle where it
releases water and eventually melts
this new injection of hot material rises
until it encounters the base of the
continental slab where it has no choice
but to spread out dragging adjacent
parts of overlying continent in opposite
directions with immense friction and
under this continual relentless pull
the solid rock
cracks
a deep and widening tear forms in the
landscape a huge rift valley much like
the one threatening to rip ethiopia
kenya and tanzania in two in eastern
africa today
sometimes cracks form that are large
enough to allow molten rock to gush up
to the surface filling the floor of the
valley with black igneous basaltic rocks
but magma doesn't always make it to the
open air it flows into cracks and fills
voids deep underground where it is still
warm
here the igneous cocktail gradually
matures and its constituent minerals
separate until they can travel
independent of the mantle rocks that
gave them birth
forcing their way up through the
ever-evolving plumbing system of the
rift valley they deposit treasures of
gemstones like amethyst and valuable
metals like raw
native copper
[Music]
this mid-continent rift system was a
truly immense rip in the fabric of
ancient laurentia the largest of its
kind to ever threaten the integrity of
the long-lived american craton its
expansion continued for around 20
million years and had almost reached the
edge of the continent to allow the
waters of the global ocean to burst
through and fill the rift valley
if they had then the grenville belt and
its associated mountains could have been
rent violently from the rest of
laurentia the present-day north american
continent would have been reduced to
perhaps two-thirds of its current size
with the usa deprived of the entire east
coast florida to maine would belong to
another continent entirely or be left
adrift as an island on its own and the
american midwest would be drowned ripped
in two and relegated to the continental
shelves of a new
mid-continental ocean
but it was not to be
before irreparable damage could be done
the forces that fed the nascent rift
system suddenly and decisively came to
an end
this mid-continent rift that promised so
much
simply
failed
it never grew any larger and it never
reached the sea but it did remain as a
whole in the heart of the continent part
of which was eventually filled by river
water and runoff to form the immense
waters of lake superior
this lake the largest freshwater body in
the world by surface area occupies just
a fraction of the vast mid-continental
rift system
and today all around its shore as well
as on the isle royale the treasures of
the deep can be found the copper that
was once exploited by native american
ancestors owes its existence to the
little rift that couldn't
and is a testament to the sheer tectonic
power that creaks and groans beneath our
feet
so laurentia stayed in one piece
suffering only at its edge with the
collision and assimilation of amazonia
and rio plateau
on the scale of the entire rodinian
supercontinent this was little more than
a cosmetic adjustment compared to what
could have been had the mid-continent
rift sustained
it seems the rut of the boring billion
is too deep to escape
even with all the tectonic might that
the earth can muster
but the supercontinent is less than half
of the global story
there is air and water and life
elsewhere on our neoproterozoic world
could conditions here promise any relief
from the monotony
some 2000 meters below the shimmering
surface of the black sea 80 kilometers
from the coast of bulgaria a small
remote operated submarine descends in
silence
it is dark here much further than
sunlight from the surface can penetrate
and so the little submersible rover must
rely on its powerful headlights to
document its progress towards the sea
floor
a fine rain of dead plankton drifts down
around it
shining brightly in the artificial glare
looking just like snow
otherwise
there is nothing to mark its descent
through the blackness
without warning the headlights tilted
slightly down illuminate the sea floor
and the submersible thrusters switch
direction churning up the floating sea
snow in order to keep the craft from
plowing into the deep smooth ooze
through its camera lenses scientists on
the sunlit research ship at the surface
see what the robot craft sees as it
strafes along inside of the bottom
and before long their search
is rewarded
the velvety silt of the sea floor
embraces the unmistakable curve
of a ship's bow
and beyond it the diffuse lamp beam
reveals a mast still standing proudly
from a deck with rowing benches
along with twin rudders at the rear
the wreck of this wooden ship is
remarkably well preserved it looks like
it fell to the bottom of the black sea
less than a decade ago but its design
betrays a great antiquity
it bears striking resemblance to boats
depicted in classical artworks that
decorate ancient greek vases such as the
one that carried odysseus on his along
an eventful voyage
and indeed when the submersible extracts
a splinter of wood for carbon dating the
shipwreck is confirmed to be nearly two
and a half thousand years old
this
is the oldest intact shipwreck ever
discovered and it owes its remarkable
preservation to the unique conditions
of the black sea
covering an area of nearly half a
million square kilometers the black sea
is likely to be so named in english
because of the dark colour of its waters
while its name in greek derives from the
phrase inhospitable sea
many seas around the world are
treacherous but the black sea's peril
extends deep below the waves
descend more than about 200 meters and
just when the light begins to run out so
too
does the oxygen
more than 90 percent of the black sea's
volume is entirely anoxic excluding
anything that needs oxygen to live
in the sea's deep water mass no fish or
seaweed can survive
only bacteria capable of turning food
into energy without oxygen are to be
found below in the deepest darkest
depths
it is this immense exclusion zone that
allows such intricate shipwrecks to be
preserved over millennia without oxygen
the kinds of creatures that would
normally colonize and destroy the
energy-rich wood are kept at bay the
greek ship along with more than 60
others spanning the black sea's long
history have been pickled and mummified
in the black ooze of the anoxic sea
bottom
the unique conditions of the black sea
basin are possible today because even
while the global ocean is homogenized by
the exchange of water between the icy
poles and steamy tropics the black sea
is shut off from this global mixing bowl
by the narrowest of inlets but one
billion years ago in the neoproterozoic
it was the entire ocean that was
subjected to the bizarre anoxic
stratification
without ice at the poles to help mix
upper and lower water layers the vast
super ocean that spanned the opposite
hemisphere to rodinia stagnated and
oxygen if it had ever penetrated the
abyssal plains was gradually excluded
this strange chemical situation may be
hard to imagine given that life capable
of photosynthesis had almost certainly
been on the scene for one and a half
billion years pumping out its waste
oxygen into the atmosphere with
photosynthetic organisms spreading
around the globe it would seem
straightforward to chart a course from
the carbon dioxide rich oxygen-poor
world of before to the oxygen-rich
carbon dioxide poor world of today
indeed the air exchanges its chemistry
with the ocean so there had surely been
more than enough time for oxygen to
accumulate throughout the entire water
column but on a global scale things are
never so straightforward before the
world could transform into the one we
know now the one that allows the plants
animals and modern day microbes to
thrive it first had to pass through a
very ugly greasy and stinky adolescence
the explosion of photosynthetic
organisms in the shallow sunlit waters
cease huge quantities of organic matter
made in the shallows
when these floating plankton eventually
die they sink into the dark ocean depths
like the marine snow falling through the
black sea's merc
there it provides the perfect energy
source for scavenger microbes which
decay and consume the organic matter
using up oxygen in the process just like
we digest our food with the help of
oxygen we breathe
thus what little oxygen makes it into
the deeper parts of the ocean is used up
while other bacteria which don't need
oxygen to digest their food use exotic
metabolic chemistry to get their energy
transforming sulfate into hydrogen
sulfide and driving not only anoxic but
sulfur-rich eugenic conditions worldwide
the result is an eerie dark purple or
even black super ocean that stretches
for half the entire globe
these sulfurous deep waters would be
deadly to the majority of modern marine
life even the simple microbes that exist
at this time and which have rained
throughout the oceans for billions of
years now find themselves quarantined to
the ocean layers that can support them
photosynthesis still reigns supreme in
the surface waters the inexhaustible
wash of light energy is too bountiful a
resource to shirk
but not all that photosynthesis is as we
know it
when anoxic waters swell up into the
ocean's top 200 sunlit meters it
encourages exotic life forms that can
make the best of both worlds
photosynthesis without producing oxygen
and a metabolism without needing it
either
this oddly layered ocean with its native
lifeforms isolated among the chemical
conditions they can withstand helps to
explain why oxygen levels continued to
remain low well into the neoproterozoic
despite the gases first appearance one
and a half billion years earlier
life could survive but it was hardly a
comfortable boundless existence
oxygen may have stayed low throughout
the boring billion and into the
neoproterozoic but other atmospheric
gases waste products of the exotic
chemistry in the ocean were in healthy
abundance
carbon dioxide levels are lower than
they have been since the atmosphere's
creation as it is gobbled up by
photosynthesizers and drawn down into c4
sediments but its warming effects are
more than made up for by other more
potent greenhouse gases
exotic metabolisms release methane and
nitrous dioxide into the air which help
to keep the entire globe about four
degrees celsius warmer than today
despite the younger sun being as much as
10 percent dimmer
modern day global warming has
highlighted the difference that just a
few degrees of global temperature can
make on the climate and one billion
years ago the impacts of such warmth
were no different
the continent of rodinia spanned the
equator but failed to reach either pole
and without land to stabilize ice sheets
it's unlikely that any ice persisted all
year round perhaps the dark polar
winters would see the ocean freeze over
with transient ice and perhaps
temperatures could drop low enough high
in the grenville mountains to allow
glaciers and snow-capped ranges to
survive
but for the large part the climate is
hot
wet and very
very energetic
the super ocean is a vast breeding
ground for tropical storms
as the sun warms the equatorial regions
and the potent greenhouse gases lock in
that warmth the surface ocean evaporates
pouring ever more warmth and more energy
into the atmosphere
coriolis forces curl and twist air
currents into powerful self-sustaining
worlds that race angrily across the
blackened waves gaining strength with
every passing mile
eventually with winds that reach several
hundred miles an hour rains that fill
the skies with water and storm surges
that inundate the cliff tops these
immense cyclones hurl themselves against
the rodinian shoreline they continually
batter and erode bringing with them the
unmistakable stench of rotten eggs as
hydrogen sulfide from the eugenic ocean
depths is whipped up and into the stormy
air
black sludge dredged from the deep
[Music]
and so the air and oceans are still just
as disagreeable as the rodinian
continent itself
desolate land stinking oceans steamy
roiling atmosphere all contribute to a
neoproterozoic earth that is no
different to the age that has gone
before
but
somewhere on this miserable planet
there is
a glimmer of hope
it is small isolated and precarious but
it could just be the eden from which our
habitable world
is built anew
on christmas day 2021 an ariane rocket
lifted off from the spaceport in french
guiana carrying with it an
extraordinarily expensive and precious
payload
the james webb space telescope
in development for over 30 years and
costing more than 10 billion dollars
this innovative space telescope promises
to herald the next generation of space
exploration using its incredibly
sensitive infrared sensors to probe the
universe for clues to its birth and
evolution
it will study some of the cosmos
earliest moments charting the lives and
deaths of stars and galaxies
and it will probe the atmospheres of
exoplanets with unprecedented detail
searching for signs of extraterrestrial
life
as the rocket faded into the brightening
morning sky scientists all over the
world breathed a cautious sigh of relief
the most perilous stage of its journey
was complete
nearly 1500 people were involved in the
design build and deployment of the james
webb space telescope
but nasa's ranks boast more than 10
times that number there are the rocket
scientists the engineers the planetary
scientists the planetary protection
officers
and then there are
the exobiologists
film and television usually depict their
jobs as glamorous and exciting listening
to cryptic signals from little green men
or poring over photos from mars rovers
looking for signs of alien civilization
indeed it will be these exobiologists
who will analyze webb's exoplanet data
for the kinds of molecules only life can
produce
but most of the time the exobiologist's
job is much more mundane we have not to
date discovered life on any planet other
than earth and so if we hope to find it
or even to know where to look in the
vast expanse of space we must first
understand what constrains life
right here
where can
living things thrive
where might they eke out a living
where could they not possibly hang on
[Music]
and so a summer afternoon finds a small
group of exobiologists on a field trip
from nasa ames the administration center
in california's silicon valley their
destination is a slough a river delta
turned tidal flat on the state's pacific
coast
as they park up and head out along the
braided streams music from a roadside
diner blares out and the smell of
barbecue ribs floats over the faintly
stagnant air
it is not the most alien of environments
but it nevertheless has what they are
looking for
close to the water's edge the soft brown
ooze is covered with a woven and tufted
mat of green
it is the perfect environment for
photosynthetic algae
a flat stable surface nice and moist and
continuously exposed to the sun but
thrusting a spade through this yielding
biofilm into the compacted sediments
beneath reveals a spectacular rainbow of
colours
this sedimentary spectrum is created by
layers of algae and bacteria neatly
stacked and layered organized according
to their metabolic needs and preferences
oxygenic photosynthesizers at the top
give way to bacteria that still need
oxygen but do not require light
deeper where the oxygen from the surface
can't penetrate always all used up there
are myriad and oxygenic forms each
utilizing a particular chemical compound
and producing waste products which the
bacteria in the lower echelons can use
this colorful hierarchy fills the tidal
mud flats out of sight making best use
of every possible geological resource
it is a useful analogy for thinking how
life might survive on a nutrient-starved
exoplanet
or indeed on the neoproterozoic earth
the billion-year-old ocean may seem like
a stinking toxic waste ground to us but
just like the layered communities of the
californian tidal flats it is actually
an ideal environment in which to breed
diversity
living things persisted on earth for
more than a billion years before the
appearance of any oxygen at all so its
scarcity in the deep dark oceans is no
great loss there are still minerals
washed from the supercontinent's surface
still nutrients being pumped in via deep
hydrothermal vents
there is plenty of energy in the water
if you know how to use it
complex eukaryotic cells appeared
sometime in the last billion years as
just such a response to the ocean's
frugal living conditions every
multicellular organism alive on earth
today is a eukaryote and can trace its
ancestry back to a moment sometime in
the early proterozoic when simpler
prokaryotic cells combined in mutual
cooperation
compared with the simple bacterium
eukaryotes are spectacularly complex
containing within them the equivalent of
several of their prokaryotic brethren
but these larger cells correspondingly
have much higher energy and nutrient
requirements
they need more nitrogen and phosphorus
to help build their larger and more
convoluted cell machinery and yet these
are the compounds that are in shortest
supply
so despite being more efficient and more
adaptable to different environments
eukaryotes still find themselves elbowed
out of many parts of the stratified
ocean the environment instead favors
life forms that are able to supply their
own nitrogen and phosphorus like the
prokaryotic cyanobacteria
there are still places where eukaryotes
can thrive however and the relative
stasis of the boring billion has allowed
them to experiment with new forms new
metabolisms new cellular architecture
slowly gradually and hidden in the
shadows eukaryotes are developing the
adaptations that will help them dominate
and shape the world we see today
billion-year-old rocks exposed by
melting ice retreating from somerset
island in arctic canada reveal
exceptionally preserved fossils of
remarkable new eukaryotic forms
and these glassy tombs contain more
complex cellular forms than have ever
been seen on earth before moreover they
are almost identical to the modern day
red algae that can be found colonizing
the shoreline rocks and tidal flats of
somerset island and elsewhere the modern
algae is called banger and its fossil
counterpart preserved in intricate
detail is bangio morpha
the fossils of bangio morpha reveal an
association of disc shaped cells
creating long filaments that are routed
to an ancient surface
they grow upwards to the light and at
their tips they bloom and expand into
bulbous masses with many more cells
they look provocatively similar to the
fruiting reproductive bodies of modern
day algae and seaweed
this paleontologists believe is evidence
of something special happening among
these early eukaryotes it appears that
bangio morpha has developed an efficient
strategy for reproducing
sexually
until now primitive prokaryotes have
reproduced largely through the simple
act of cloning genetic variation is
introduced through mutations and through
a complex trading of genetic material
that is totally unrelated to
reproduction
but eukaryotes have much more advanced
cellular machinery and so now have the
ability and incentive to invent a much
more involved reproductive dance
it is less efficient than the
prokaryotic way requiring two parents to
make a single offspring but properly
executed it brings with it the
possibility of much greater variation
and correspondingly better adaptation
and faster evolution
today bacteria may be able to trade the
information needed to evade a certain
antibiotic but only sexually reproducing
eukaryotes are able to evolve entire new
body parts simply by the recombination
of genes in a generation
sex with the differentiation of gendered
forms of a given organism helps bangio
morpher to innovate faster to avoid the
perils of error-prone cloning and to
stay one step ahead of their prokaryotic
brethren
it is the beginning of a glorious if
complicated dance that will come to
define the lives of all eukaryotes
for a billion years
[Music]
meanwhile the rodinian supercontinent
is still barren
despite a bounty of minerals ripe for
the taking in the newly crumpled
grenville mountains and elsewhere the
sun is still a deadly laser beaming
damaging uv rays across the land surface
there is not yet enough oxygen in the
atmosphere to create an effective ozone
barrier and so the only production to be
found is beneath water
since its beginnings in the deep oceans
life has dominated there but it is not
particular about which bodies of water
it chooses to colonize
and so as the earth rotates a little
faster than today and the sun rises
rapidly over the east coast of rodinia
the morning light washes inland from the
shore
slowly suffusing the undulating
foothills with a soft golden glow
and among the pale pastel blush
is a piercing highlight
a bright sinuous gleam as the early sun
reflects in a calm winding river higher
in the newborn grenville mountains the
shadows linger a little longer but the
shining ribbon pierces the darkness as
it winds up leading the eye eventually
to a still
golden pond
a lake nestled among the snow-covered
mountain peaks
it is just one of the freshwater
torridon lakes the sediments of which
now make up much of the rocks of the
western scottish coast
including the anthrax poisoned grignard
island
here it is high enough in altitude and
latitude for the lake to freeze over in
the winter and rethaw each summer
it is large enough in area and depth to
persist for tens of millions of years
and it is here that we will find the
ingredients
for remaking
our
[Music]
world the toridon lakes are completely
isolated from the global ocean and so
they are not forced to share its
stratified fate the regular flow of
water and the seasonal cooling and
warming are enough to keep the lake
waters mixed and oxygenated keeping the
stinking hydrogen sulfide at bay
they are more like today's oceans and
lakes even with the low oxygen in the
atmosphere and the mountains that tower
over them ensure a plentiful supply of
biologically important nitrogen and
phosphorus as a result these lakes
are full
of life
the lake microbes ancestors may have
followed the river courses upstream to
their new home or they may have been
blown in on the powerful cyclone winds
but once there they found the torridan
lakes to be a veritable eden
there was so much phosphate in the water
that it formed a glassy gel that trapped
some of the abundant life forms before
they could decay away preserving for a
billion years a picture of the
remarkable diversity of these isolated
lakes
and so paleontologists have discovered
more than 20 species of fossils from
cyanobacterial filaments to larger
complex cells with protective outer
coverings and even to tiny scavenger
bacteria hoovering up the spare organic
matter that falls to the lake bottom
and there is another new and curious
form among them a fossil that its
discoverers have named by sellum
like bangiomorphur in the oceans it
contains different cell types within a
single discrete body by selum has a mass
of equidimensional cells packed into a
ball surrounded by a shell of elongated
sausage-shaped cells around the outside
several examples of this species have
been recovered showing variations in the
numbers of elongated versus spherical
shells around the outside
but in every case bicellum retains its
spherical shape
this implies that unlike with the algal
bango morpha the change in cell shape
doesn't result in the change in shape of
the overall organism
the individual cells that make it up
must morph and flow over one another to
accommodate the growth of certain cells
over the others and keep an overall
spherical body
the cells themselves must not be rigid
but fluid and flexible
much like the cells that make up our own
and every other animal's bodies
and indeed by selling has been
interpreted as a multicellular holozoan
a brand new kind of organism that is a
stepping stone on the road to true
animals
it is a remarkable evolutionary
innovation and one that was potentially
only possible in this isolated eden far
away from the stratified austerity of
the global ocean
and so as the door closes on one chapter
of earth's history and opens onto the
neoproterozoic
change is in the air
there is still a lot of bizarre and
unrecognizable chemistry painting the
ocean's black and the endless continent
red
but this is the last time in earth's
history that our planet would appear
quite so alien to us
in an inconspicuous lake behind a
snow-covered mountain range a tiny slice
of paradise appears as a flash of golden
green
and it is beneath these waters one
billion years ago that we can finally
glimpse the wonders of complex life
that are soon to sweep the globe
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
i will see you
next time
[Music]
you